cantando y ondeando banderas decenas de
personas siguen protestando a las
afueras de las viviendas del presidente
decir lanka y el primer ministro señales
de que meses de protestas pacíficas
finalmente se han salido de control en
sir lanka los manifestantes dicen que no
tienen intención de irse hasta que los
dos líderes renuncien oficialmente el
presidente gotabaya rajapaksa prometió
su renuncia oficial el próximo miércoles
pero la gente sigue escéptica
y que es vía norte él ya destruyó
nuestra confianza la confianza de
nuestro país y ya vendió nuestra nación
así que no estamos en posición de
confiar en él en nuestro primer ministro
en este momento no interposición tu
atrás jim o'brien y state mobile y lo
admitas de una página ávila desde niña
caminamos tres kilómetros para subirnos
a un bus y venir aquí porque queremos
ganar la batalla ya la ganamos no
queremos este gobierno necesitamos un
nuevo gobierno esperamos que el
presidente renuncia el 13 los habitantes
de la nación del sur de asia exigen una
reforma política desde hace meses para
muchos el presidente gotabaya rajapaksa
representa una dinastía familiar
política corrupta y es el culpable de la
bancarrota que atraviesa el país sir
lanka ha experimentado un aumento
precipitado en los precios del
combustible y en las materias primas
durante los últimos meses así como
cortes continuos de energía el primer
ministro es acusado de ser la mano
derecha del presidente mientras tanto
los líderes de los partidos de oposición
aún tienen que ponerse de acuerdo sobre
un gobierno de coalición alternativo lo
que volvería a poner sobre la mesa un
posible paquete de rescate del fmi